[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
good afternoon everyone welcome to
GameSpot live I'm Ritchie and today I'm
going solo Sam's out but we have a very
special occasion today it is the 20th
anniversary of the PlayStation 2 just
just listen to this listen to this
doesn't that bring back all the memories
of your childhood we're gonna be playing
a few games here today guys starting
with Metal Gear Solid 2 one of the
biggest reasons to own a Playstation 2
there were thousands of reasons but we
also have a number of games lined up
that I will let you pick a little later
on this is gonna be an extended stream
today we're going for 2 hours of just me
let's get into it huh picture and
picture bang look at that oh yeah whoo
welcome hey everybody how's it going
Connor
whoo hey Francisco welcome bez says PS 2
revealed nah man revealed 20 years ago
we're gonna get let's see man I got a
stack of games here after we play a
little metal gear I'll let you guys pick
what we should play next how we doin
y'all yesterday was the anniversary for
the switch yeah there were there was a
lot going on yesterday we couldn't
figure out what the stream because there
was too many good options oh yeah I hit
the wrong button here cool let's go for
it both I'm only gonna go for like a
half hour for this game Brandon with
star in the chat it's going on can you
guys hear me okay let me know I'm gonna
turn the game music up a little bit cuz
we all know how these cutscenes are we
got to hear them there's a lot I might
skip through some of it great archetype
- hey
hmm I'm not that Pro I'm not gonna go
with the the radar off I needed man I
was just telling John Luke who thank you
for helping me out by the way John Luke
helped me out
set up the stream on the technical side
of things so fast two years ago oh yeah
there it is
we had classified intelligence that a
new type of Metal Gear was scheduled to
transport the whole thing stank
but our noses have been out in the cold
too long okay
we're on borrowed time here guys with
this stream I'm gonna get through a lot
of these games so I'm gonna skip some
cutscenes it's all about the gameplay
right now actually with Metal Gear a lot
of talk about the story really we'll see
let me know in the chat I'm at this me
what you guys favorite cookies -
memories were favorite game shout him
Ally Andy this was one of mine for sure
but I was telling John Luke when this
launch I played it of course but I had
no idea what I was getting into you know
I played a few years later and I was
like yikes this game was way too
objective ahead of its time it was crazy
it's a it's a very political stance on
it it's crazy as your gear like it is
way too whoa there's a tranquilizer gun
convert it from here we go Paolo yes
Metal Gear - man we are celebrating the
anniversary the 20th anniversary of the
PlayStation 2 playing some some classics
man we scooped up a little bit Russians
I know I'm sure sorry I skipped the
intro I had to touch that we're gonna be
playing a lot of games today but if you
want to see a dedicated metal twisted
metal Metal Gear Solid 2 stream someday
let me know all that stuff's fun I'm
gonna be skipping a lot though look at
look at this I'm on it I'll let you guys
pick later but we got Midnight Club Sly
Cooper I'm gonna be playing some God of
War for sure a morgue
no Skippy Skippy you guys really don't
want me to skip this all right I'll stop
skipping
but you're gonna see less of the games
we need to get a fix on who they are
about the codec talks it's gonna skip
this I'm just gonna live I'm gonna skip
it without your permission
look at that it's over whoops yeah
Filipe says Metal Gear 2 Sons of Liberty
as legend yes yes yes yes so much oh so
very much look at this here we go whoo
give me my buttons all correct mm-hmm
look I already already alerted the damn
guards I'm fooling around too much no no
no no don't come at me shoot he knows
where I'm at though and there's another
guard to my left time to hide Ratchet
and Clank says firestorm heck yeah
all right that you didn't end up coming
for me or he's taking too long
Francisco says God of War yes I have
that in my stack Oh games right here we
can play that if you want I will leave
it up to you after I play a little
middle gear here choice is yours friends
I got a lot of options we have a massive
library of games oh oh all right guy
number one left so I'm gonna go back
around that way I just want to confirm
my button layout here it's looking good
oh man good stuff
all right
something over here who I made a knock
sound I'll try to jump over there we go
a little chap grenade I guess I don't
need to get all I need to find
everything we're only gonna be playing
for a little bit here
there's the camera up top let's get my
mic up a little bit can you guys hear me
okay I'm sure it's fine but let me know
if I need to balance some sound I forget
can I go in this one right away a lot
damn too easy right I just beat this guy
up go for a chokehold going for it Oh
flip instead whoops shoot OOP oh there
it goes whoo
obsolete says gran turismo heck yeah no
I know how to open the door dude the
rain effects are sick for the ps2 game
yeah yeah they are this was this this
whole game is so memorable especially
this kanker mission okay that's CQC okay
oh yeah here we go I'm trying to
remember how to do that like somersault
yeah there it is just press X maybe I
can go around this way or hmm yeah I'll
just go through this deck over here
Logan wolf says Fright Night heck yeah
Donkey Kong says I'm shocked this
masterpiece has never been on a Nintendo
console yeah they're doing a lot of
porting they're doing a lot of m-rated
games that are getting ported what's the
hold up I don't know they have some sort
of forever exclusivity although you guys
remember this game was eventually ported
to the original Xbox
yeah Paolo is admiring the details of
this game we've got it running through
an original PlayStation 2 console hooked
up via the framemeister so it's up
scaled a little bit with some component
cables to HDMI out so it's looking as
good as it gets friends how am i doing
am I in frame oh yeah
mm hmm let's see here hmm oh there he
goes
guys remember all the little did you
guys hide in the lockers very much I
felt like that was a good technique but
I can never I always I was always
freaking out too much about getting
caught like the controller beeps like
simulates your heart I couldn't take it
I also never hit the bodies in the
lockers I was just always so rogue
that's me yes we are playing on a ps2
the only thing that's off is that I
couldn't find a ps2 controller but a ps1
controller works wonderfully
Iko is a masterpiece oh yeah that game
push the limits of the console here go
for the head shot what'd you guys name
oh yeah wha Ratchet and Clank oh yeah
let's see yeah I didn't get anything
whatever he'll wake up I'll get in
trouble I'm out of here
I know gun foo says I never played any
Metal Gear games but um you want to play
this one this is a good one to start
with although you can't I'd be torn to
suggest that wholeheartedly because I'd
want you to play the one for the ps1
Metal Gear Solid 1 same care oh shoot I
goofed up already oh no this is what you
wanted to see right hey I got him before
he called back up oh shoot I forgot I'm
out of here
no no don't send backup oh they're gonna
come upstairs I think I did that on
purpose
oh shoot nice I don't have a USB yet
dude why is this guy stink and there's
so many flies alright check keep
listening off your favorite PlayStation
2 games we're playing this today this is
locked because the PlayStation 2 turns
20 years old today are some of you guys
even 20 years old in the chat like damn
I'm feeling old but the memories live on
you know this is awesome
alright which way should I go that's
open mm-hmm no but they saw me right as
I left ah Louis says I won't be able to
use the pressure-sensitive controls with
the ps1 controller that's right huh they
introduced it with the new ps4 all right
what the hell am i doing which I have
it's been it's been a while guys I
played this when it came out when it was
remastered for the PlayStation 3 but
that's been it's been a while I know I
have to get up and meet Olga but
she's upstairs and I keep going down oh
I broke the damn handle Oh max Rob says
mortal kombat armageddon was fun I
played it I didn't play it I kind of
fell off the mortal kombat around this
this era of gaming how about you guys
when when they started to get any to the
story I kind of I lost a little track I
lost I got off track but you know with
the later editions like 9 10 11 I played
a little more for sure all right I'm
cool I'm going around in circles here
guys
please excuse me all right there's one
more guy over there I'm gonna ignore him
I think I have to go up this I came from
this way before but now I'm gonna go
this way that's locked
all right hmm mm-hmm
jak and daxter The Godfather was good
again some more more favorite games I
keep going in circles all right I got to
focus a little bit sorry I'm trying to
I'm trying to focus on chat - it's
locked if I go down there I believe we
go back up here this guy over here
hasn't noticed this just as soon as I
said that he noticed his friend dammit
all right well I'm gonna take him out -
I don't want him waking up his hell me
James asked what did you guys think of
Metal Gear Solid five discuss yes
discuss gta3 is a must I consider that
for today's stream for sure I did we
played it kind of recently though site I
took it off the list but we got a lot of
options here
I even got Simpsons road rage burnout
whatever you guys want to play oh oh
here we go making some progress
Raven no no no GTA san andreas yep that
is one of my all-time favorites good
times right I put so many hours into
that game remember this
Need for Speed Underground heck yeah
light saber samurai says the ps2 is the
greatest console of all time
a lot of fans of jak and daxter mm-hmm I
hate when this happened you guys know
when this is locked and there is a
technique to to open it with like a
certain way to kick it but every time I
try to punch and kick it it falls in
word and I I never do it right watch I'm
gonna screw it up again for you guys for
chat I think I just have to like kick it
ah forget it I hate this locker I'm
going away now oh shoot
by shooting it done that oh [ __ ] great
now they're gonna tattle on me try to
kill me where do you think you're going
pal okay maybe maybe that solved itself
we'll have to see here I need to go to
Olga upstairs first I think I'm on the
way to do that now I feel I'm finally in
a new area it's been a while since I've
sat down and played this game you guys
thank you for being here
sharing your ps2 memories good times
right oh shoot this guy got up bad times
yo there we go did his friend die I'm
pretty sure his friend I mean it's
comrade oh shoot
anything over here I knew it okay no no
no I hated that I loved it and I hated
it it's such a good a I move to like
call in reinforcements I need to play
burnout three you saw that right I have
it I might play it I love that game
although there's a lot of good music
that I just remembered his on there and
might not be able to flick it with music
I probably should but shoot I love that
game so much oh shoot it's over for me
folks they have the riot shields and
everything I goofed up hard hey kill the
one guy Ziya
yeah I'm gonna die I know where to go to
this is the worst part maybe I can do
that flip over the edge
alright suckas we'll see how long this
works they're probably gonna find me and
I don't have a box or anything I'm I'm
doomed
yep I do have to play God of War don't I
you know what though in this stack I
only have God of War 1 hmm
we'll see I definitely want to play that
Lehrer says happy 20th anniversary PSU
woohoo it is that's why we're here today
folks I'm playing some ps2 classes
alright waiting for everything to clear
up here did I play Killzone for the ps2
no I definitely remember but I just I
never bought it ooh Tekken Tag yep DMC
is my favorite sorry I'm now I'm just
now I'm just reading the chat like
exclusively alright what is the most
difficult ps2 game I don't know man you
guys tell me
alright I'm going I'm going I'm going
[Music]
No yes I shot his mic you're out son I
got to get out of here now doing this
I'm such a rookie whatever I got him I
clear my way through this is where I
need to be there we go
of course Francisco says Kingdom Hearts
you know what I also have that for
today's stream if we want to play oh
yeah okay come on
alright gosh I love that poster it's so
stupid it's like the back of the poster
that's in front so silly
okay there's bombs here I'm gonna watch
the eff out two more eyes telling me to
get the dog tags I don't know man I'm
not I can i I'm not that good that I'm
not gonna own shoe I can't even stay off
the radar two more no way no that's it
I'm just gonna commit suicide it's over
[Music]
crazy
yeah well it was either this or get
caught and have to painfully fight
through everybody so I saved you guys
interesting
I need the USP yeah it's loud I don't
even think has the silence silence until
later but flick says Ghost Recon yes
keep sharing this is great I also have
Sly Cooper oh look see look look where
it put me perfect perfect come on oh
yeah I need to get it upstairs we just
talked about that alright I forget if I
can you just crawl under this or do I
have to do all this I neither you it
that's why you guys are saying I need
the USP to shoot these bombs I can't
crawl under Jack squat here oh gosh
alright alright why am i crawling you
know
let's see more us people it's yep yep
yep yep yep all right
Chad if you remember remind me where
exactly I get the USP cuz I'm not gonna
be wasting that much time not wasting
time I'm not gonna be spend the whole
stream playing this game so I got to
find the USP ASAP like I dead dead AF
all right cool
manhunt says star yeah I saw that in the
library today I was like do I do this
I'm not gonna put it on screen no no oh
shoot this is already enough of a
manhunt I'm killing people here but that
game was yeah that's up there that was
dark
this is get in
there's something over here one gosh
they're giving me so many bullets and I
don't have the dang USP us no don't even
going the right way to go back here we
go hmm hey a rational hearing all these
sounds and voice lines like is somebody
there and then this hearing this like Oh
like getting them knocked out it's all
so nostalgic but so many this oh shoot
oh dang you know what's not nostalgic
actually this is pretty installed you're
getting killed by all the guards over
and over again this is just like how I
play it the first time right how many
times did I die a bunch whoo the tension
series is pretty awesome
you already know how I feel about you
all right well this will give me a clean
opportunity to go back silently oh man
is it in here if it's in here that's
good but I'm just okay I know where I am
now all right more love for jak and
daxter in the chat the gunner says they
need a remake of this game oh damn it
was still not out where is the USP take
that ration heck yeah
there are so many little things you can
do to piss off the guards like kind of
quietly in this game I'm kind of running
through it but so much like attention to
fund attention to detail is put into
this game hmm Call of Duty 3 says
Francisco mm-hmm oh my goodness
all right thank you Nocturne I am going
back I get the USP after fighting Olga
according to him I'm gonna take your
word for it after that fight I think
I'll probably move on to the next game
because we got a I got a stack full of
games I'm gonna play I think like
roughly for three or four games there's
way too many memories with this you know
I got it I had to narrow it down but I
did bring a stack of games and I'll let
you guys pick what's next arrow says
Splinter Cell and firestorm - the
Splinter Cell - mm-hmm okay well if I
can't how do I take these out then can I
crawl under them or shoot them with m9
no the m9 doesn't do jack squat all
right well like or is it these uh guys
um my memories fading what do I do
exactly I'm not gonna no probably won't
do it what is what is Otto Kahn say help
me out bro oh I keep pressing X there
you go X backs you out take a close look
yeah yeah the thing with blinking green
lights right now oh the green thing I
was shooting the c4 like an idiot a
control unit for the sense wow dude
destroy that and the sensor stopped
functioning all right all right getting
close enough to touch it so you'll have
to shoot it out but your m9s knockout
rounds won't work find it guns see okay
all right I do have to find another gun
no I don't want to call you again
yeah great all right guys let's see here
but to fight Olga I think I think uh
someone in the chat was saying earlier I
think was Nocturne it is after the fight
with all go I'm just going the wrong way
- to start that fight with her
crap I'm doing it all wrong oh shoot oh
I thought I would beat up to the call
pong pieces I forgot this game bro how
would ever hopefully have some good
memories of it not not everyone in the
world has played Metal Gear you know and
by the looks of it it doesn't look like
I've ever played Metal Gear time-sucking
get up
ha
oh yeah well that didn't do jack squat
cuz I'm gonna get surrounded he kicked
me this is a messy guys
goodbye cruel world oh [ __ ] hahaha they
got me
ooh I should play games X for the ps2 I
did see that in the library - we have
our GameSpot library and there were a
ton of games Danilo says I forgot this
part - yeah this is a teaser you knows
the beginning of the game before you and
play as riding you know what's gonna
troll around for a little bit I don't
know if I can make it to the gun with a
comfortable amount of time let's see
here yeah that dudes dead alright going
back yeah what is this I didn't notice
this before ah teasing me with us people
it's over and over and over
got some memories more memories in the
chat keep them coming
yeah I didn't buy memory card at first
yeah I borrowed an uncle's memory card
and I still have it to this day you kind
of just let me have it
but if you ask him about it he'll tell
you yeah that's still my memory card go
away dude man now it's on nothing on
says shinobi is a hard game you know I
don't think I played it on the ps2 I
can't see all right here we go I'm just
going for it I'm gonna get in so much
trouble again quit shooting me no this
is just going oh no goodness oh yeah
they saw me for sure it's over I am NOT
doing this game justice I'm having fun
this is all about remembering oh jeez
attacking the power of juju should be
next says Jane do I have that I don't
have it in my stack all right one more
one or two more a chance and then I'm
gonna move on because we've got a few
more games to play the new SOCOM game
will be called zero six I should play
Prince of Persia I didn't see it in the
library
God man forgot how punishing this game
is I should have put it on baby mode
nice Dave's ex should be next I don't
have it in my stack my friend I'm sorry
I didn't I don't think I saw that in the
library either we have a we have a ton
of PlayStation 2 games in our game spot
library and I I just try to find like
the you know ones that at least I played
jeez sorry I'm never getting out of this
ooh
pinchy fatal Shadow sorry that guy
reading that was the death of me but
it's worth it God of War please okay
let's leave it up to the chat I'm gonna
I'm gonna keep this screen on just for a
sec free my hands and make you guys
decide what you play next I have well I
have to just my headphones Kingdom
Hearts 1 option love that game Sly
Cooper oh yeah midnight club God of War
God of War - oh this is the special
features disc this might not be the game
[ __ ] but I do have God of War oh no yeah
God of War - right here disc 1 God of
War 2 is an option no you guys have to
pick from this list I'm not gonna get up
and go pick another game can't burn out
oh yeah burn out three Max Payne and The
Simpsons
road rage I'm seeing a lot of God of War
Gran Turismo I don't have that in this
stack currently so far looks like Oh
realm of chaos
SSX I don't have that either it's like
Cooper okay
the the the makeshift poll the results
are looking pretty foggy right now I
need some more votes
no seriously Sly Cooper burn out three
got a four - whoo you guys better decide
it's it this is pretty varied I got a
good stack here huh
let's see hmm God of War okay it's
getting close between I have to narrow
it down you guys God of War because we
have time for two more of these so God
of War and Sly Cooper are the most right
now hmm God of War might be a to
not-safe-for-work to more you killing me
brother fine
you know what Sly Cooper was a close
second burn dang we're getting a lot for
burn out three oh yeah there's a stream
delay my bad y'all midnight club you
guys are not making this easy all right
this is tough now the stream is flooding
oh my god this is this is crazy all
right I'm just gonna pick one because I
can play I've got another we extended
the stream to another an extra half hour
so I'm gonna get through more of these
why don't you stop talking and play some
burnout let's go I'm gonna take out this
game from the console and swap I'll be
right back
oh I know you guys heard that oh yeah
alright this I'm gonna play some burnout
and then we'll vote later for the next
one
I did this in the beginning of the chat
or the beginning of the stream but just
listen to this sound you guys remember
that so fondly
how many PlayStation 2 games did you
guys have
I had like say like 20-ish like I didn't
go crazy cuz I was also I was I'd like
just had my first job so I was buying
these games on my own but I didn't get a
lot as gifts to discs ever no don't say
that huh Hampi knows no disc era we're
playing some burnout and it's working
don't scare me like that all right no
ps2 card no memory card that's fine do
you want to start yeah man hey come on
controller oh this controllers not
working it was work
no you guys the controller isn't working
wait all right it's yeah it's going into
demo mode because this isn't working
diggin it maybe some games are not 100%
compatible with this controller
I gotta have to swap out you guys
burnout is a no-go for now I'll play
this though actually I can't even do
that because uh this is probably a
copyrighted song gotta go all right I'm
bringing the mic with me actually now we
know it now we can vote we can vote
again a quick vote actually no no no
voting because Sly Cooper was a second
choice so we're going for it if this
doesn't work with the controller I've
got I don't even know what I'm gonna do
y'all
the thing is this morning excuse me this
afternoon I found you know our our
Playstations we got a few but I cannot
find a ps2 controller and I know the
DualShock one works fine so I'm trying
to figure out I guess for some games not
for all of them that's what's going on
here I think
Tamura says Kingdom Hearts I went with
Sly Cooper man sorry there's a stream
delay okay all right let's see if this
works
geez tomorrow maybe if you can help me
out with the ps2 controller if you're
still watching because I'm certain that
not all games are working with this
controller Tekken 5 we're getting some
more some more options okay this seems
to be working
[Music]
let me turn it up you're safe in the fan
I'm the thief here I'm got to steal that
file from Inspector Carmelita Fox okay
there are ton of votes for Max Payne so
after this I'm going I got you just keep
that engine running Murray I'll be down
at Norris Max Payne for sure is Nix we
have a lot of early votes for this
that's why I just rolled with it but the
love for Max Payne cannot be ignored in
this chat today so here we go I'm gonna
play a little bit of this maybe you know
25 30 minutes and then it's Max Payne
time man look at this so many memories
here we go
[Music]
hey Ben I think I'm seeing things must
be vertigo or something can you see
those crazy blue lights hon P says this
is like a cartoon version button your
blue auras
I'm on it
thanks man
I'm back y'all thanks it tomorrow and
John Luke I got a proper ps2 controller
I knew there was one around here
somewhere it's more brought me - Wow
so you guys definitely remember this
game did you guys play the sequels -
sorry I missed that whole transmission
here in the beginning there we go the
analog stick works again this is going
much better kind of a sneaky around this
thing although Carol oh it was like
there we go let's hold down circle there
we go look at that oh no oh just jump
right into it no there we go okay
I literally just jump right in there got
just y'all jak and daxter was awesome
completed all three nice on the right
door
whoo these the analog controls are like
little backwards you know was early on
with analog technology I think I got it
look there's the red door duel hard says
run with chaos
aha look at this litter
I love the sound effect it's like a
rubber band like there we go yep I made
it's like filbert from Rocko's Modern
Life 937 okay oh yeah
Moe Musa hello welcome we're celebrating
the 20th anniversary of the PlayStation
2 playing a handful of games here gotta
love the voice acting Brandon hey
welcome thank you guys for joining me
today
little old me Sam is out you probably
tell cuz we started a little later today
we had a special thing going on in the
stream room beforehand that you guys
need a little late I haven't seen you
since I gave it a slip in Bombay which
reminds me you need to return the
Firestone of India to its rightful
owners haha and I was gonna give it to
you as a little token of night hey hey
you know that bazooka really brings out
the color of your eyes fetching you
think this pistol packs a paralyzing
punch you ought to try it might snap you
out of your crime spree and give up our
little rendezvous plenty of time for
that once you're safely behind bars love
to stick around and chat but I just
dropped by to pick up this case file the
boys acting first like super especially
it's very good
yep time to get the F out of here here
we are I thought we were friends
whoa safe
nevermind
got him
Brendon Brendon says I was liking that
metal gear see that Metal Gear Solid 2
gameplay I was want to bring my gang and
I'd get it wasn't doing too well but
presea being here I was surprised to see
how well she took it finally the secret
police file I've been searching for all
these years with this I could avenge my
family and regain possession of our most
valued treasure it all began when I was
just a kid
bouncing on my father's knee you see I
come from a long line of master thieves
who kept all their secrets of sneaking
and stealing in an ancient book the
Thievius Raccoonus anyone who read I
learned to be especially sneaky which is
why we specialize in stealing from
criminals after all there's no honor no
challenge no fun stealing from ordinary
people you rip off a master criminal and
you know you're a master thief well on
the night I was supposed to inherit the
book why visitors came unannounced to
our door it's so creative my father
fought to protect us but the gang of
villains known as the fiendish 5
overpowered him and ransacked our house
until they found the Thievius Raccoonus
filthy hands
Victoire the book into five pieces and
split it up each villain disappearing
that farthest corners of the
dastardly crimes
broken alone I was dumped at the town
orphanage there I met two guys who
became my life movers in trust for
Bentley don't worry Technogym accent is
ring and Marie for the part-time driver
I'm Bert whatever we're gonna get
through together we pledged to track
down the fiendish five avenge my father
and steal back the Thievius Raccoonus I
knew I was about to face the toughest
test of my life sorry I can't
on this mission I would even become a
master thief like my ancestors before me
anymore fail allow my family name to
bite the dust yeah this is like a mix of
Gilbert and Milhouse all right complete
Scarface right now oh that wasn't Roger
hit me the time I needed to study up on
sir Wally the Frog as a young man this
hot-tempered frog grew bored of his life
of luxury and privilege on a whim he
tried his hand at a bit of piracy and
found it to his liking Rowley who
quickly became addicted to crime was
brought into the fiendish 5 as cheap
machine where his evil tigran genius
ropes and new heights
oh yeah the last reported sighting of
his mad machinist was off the soggy
coast of the ILO raft a small island
uncomfortably situated in the middle of
a perilous Welsh triangle quite the
opening longer than Armand
Vaughn says this turtle reminds me of my
oldest brother alrighty
[Applause]
man so cool looking
ice why I just spotted something that's
going to complicate the mission Brandon
says I want to buy a PCSO again check
your ps4 man there's a lot of games that
were ported to the PlayStation Store
yeah sure Nocturne says I wasn't super
into skate games but SSX and SSX 3 were
amazing then hit the circuit shoulda
brought my game on max Bentley I live
for this stuff yeah relax Bentley
it was like a boss I was so cool how big
that regular-ass enemy was more clues a
well dying isn't one of them forgot that
animation with the hat yeah don't forget
a memory card says hun yeah I did
what is no biggie I'm gonna be like
marathoning a few of these games next is
you guys know Max Payne look
all right so forgot Sly Cooper cannot
swim tommy vercetti can't even swim Wow
oh goodness Moe says dead or alive oh
man good times I played that on the X
the original Xbox a lot how do we keep
skipping that first coin there we go
was there even a clue over there I might
not go back there finding the clues all
right No Hey
what the all right you guys remember
Maximo I think I had that game it kind
of raised me like something about this
game reminds me of that I don't know
what it is maybe the environments the 3d
world of it all right what did I do
wrong here
cool all right I will go fight that guy
see what's up so well let me climb this
ladder it's the strangest thing I got to
hold the button down
maybe yeah there we go yeah
realm of chaos as are the days when you
needed a memory card the struggle was
real as you know night amen y'all know
that's rubber like I had enough for the
console and the game but I don't have
enough printers the memory cards all
right can't get caught let's be sly
about this blew it I blew it
got him come on ah there we go
I make it up there not now oh yeah you
see I'm just trying to scare you let me
it's letting me like move around Bentley
beats me like metal gear you know when
you deal my families click the analogue
buttons and zoom in
no not another one of these lad there
only one hit that was very easy although
I died earlier all right I can't swim so
I'm nervous about this here we go
right this looks shallow enough though
but it moves
[Music]
right how cool this music is Filipe says
please blade
we have blade 2 in the office but I
didn't see blade warning the circle
button to grab onto hooks yep
realm of chaos keep he's he's on he's
like I would leave my playstation on all
night if I miss what to do
dang it oh yeah I was oh come on it was
there we hope
yeah thanks Bentley
these are cute
boom yeah alright guys this is a few
more minutes of this before we move on
to the the crowd favorite the chat
favorite Max Payne I know you guys want
to see that I only put this on because
you guys I thought you voted for this
then it was looking good for God of War
and Sly Cooper so I just put on some Sly
Cooper I forgot that God awards got some
like there's a lot of violence for sure
but there's even like some stuff that I
can't even show on three look at that so
much so that I died great alright
another few tries here
favorite Resident Evil game asks you
asking me to for me what about you guys
alright it's deceiving I can almost do
it like Jim no forget the coins and go
for it
alright cool
that guy looks he's not so tough right
got him
hey spider-man welcome to the chat
welcome to the stream we're celebrating
the 20th anniversary of the PlayStation
2 playing a handful of games here today
making me do the dirty work fine
ah so I go up art was that to go down
that's to go look at this look at all
this there we go I miss anything back
here ah yes another lighthouse han says
the Resident Evil 2 original was okay
but not perfect wait the remake you're
saying okay I liked it a lot yeah it's
still like I love the original Resident
Evil 2 so like nothing could compare but
they did a pretty damn good job wrong
way there we go
[Music]
yeah all right
see what's behind this door then I think
I'll move on to some Max Payne ah it's
probably the end of the little that's
right look at that
real red hood says I cannot wait for the
resident evil 3 remake did you watch the
stream today Capcom had a stream our
rumps our resident evil had a stream
showing off like a demo location on this
boat that sounds like a tall order this
is where I think I'm gonna stop apart
and move on to Max Payne what do you
guys say we got some more love for
Tekken 5 yep
Shadow of the Colossus yeah all right
personally I'm really excited and ready
for Max Payne I think I'm just gonna go
ahead and do it y'all oh yeah let me
know what y'all think in the chat I
think it's a lot it's about time
what
I'll pause here the turtle is drunk no
way man he's IQ he's our help okay guys
hang tight for just a sec while I swap
games we're gonna be playing Max Payne
next and then we'll have some time to
play a few more and I'll leave it up to
you but that's for later I'll bring the
mic over here with me there we go
man even hearing this PlayStation 2
eject the disc is so nostalgic and that
of course music to my ears
the intro to Max Payne is rough I know
you guys remember but we're about to get
into it such a good game Khan says the
gameplay looks outdated ouch man we are
using a framemeister with some component
cables so that's the best it's gonna
look man although I think they rias Sly
Cooper series and put it out for the ps4
correct me if I'm wrong click I hear you
oh my goodness look at that
woo just listen
[Music]
[Music]
oh I'm just gonna jump right in
that's right remedy you guys ever really
you guys play control last year you're
still around they're still killing it
with the games so good oh here we go
sorry the framemeister loads like that
and then it says no signal for a sec but
we all good whoo that was a throwback
for sure I'm holding the wrong
controller okay
oh man Nocturne I'm with you all the way
Capcom they do need to bring back Dino
Crisis and Onimusha huh yep oh you guys
are already feeling this all the sounds
of that whole intro brings you back down
memory lane huh here we go yeah yeah I
don't have a memory card we get it
let's go I'll wait for the music sorry I
skipped right over it I just want to
play through most of these games not
most but you know I got a stack here
games I want to like kind of get get
through but the music is good you'll
hear it
you'll hear it you know during the intro
when he's talking a 2/2 says also Breath
of Fire mm-hmm space monkey you can get
a ps2 man they're cheap nowadays I would
look into it they're very cheap
[Applause]
[Music]
no I hate this intro
[Applause]
Dharma welcome to the chat
this too loud let me know oh I keep I
pause it cuz I don't even wanna know you
guys are gonna make me watch it on this
game won't let me say we're all dead
the final gunshot was an exclamation
mark to everything that had led to this
point oh that's right
I released my finger from the trigger
and then it was over
okay I thought they were playing the
intro where you know what happens but
that was I think a little the ending
right there like they they're tearing me
don't have a sense of it I need to go
back three years back to the night the
pain started gun food says yeah in my
country I can get a ps2 for 40 bucks
yeah space monkey says I also miss
tenchu mm-hmm me too me too so much made
a whole video about it no actually 10
she was considered but I threw in Syphon
Filter we have a video about video game
series that need to come back there was
a lot on there Dino Crisis Syphon Filter
so many but check that out if you want
on the GameSpot YouTube page I did have
tension in there that was a personal or
still in the force back then NYPD
Manhattan Midtown North Precinct Hell's
Kitchen so when are you coming to work
for me
detective pain and you'd make me work
undercover in some hellhole sorry Alex
showing the baby come first see my last
smoke it's bad for the baby that's you
max a regular Boy Scout see Alex we're
still on for poker thursday night
right like taking candy from a baby so
I'm gonna push a little forward guys we
we got to get to this part so that I can
play some more games shall but I mean
anybody home I didn't like the way the
show started they've given me the best
seat in the house front row center
oh they're making me do it I forgot
all right all right just get my controls
down what the hell oh yeah you guys
remember the Max Payne movie with my
space monkey you're too kind he says
this is a good stream had to do it man
PlayStation 2 where's the damn phone
oh the controls are inverted oh well I
picked up the phone listen someone's
broken into my house call 9-1-1 is this
the pain residence yes someone's broken
into my house they're still here you
have God I'm afraid I cannot help you
oh is this hello all right
I either gotta adjust to these inverting
controls or see if I can mess with them
here
[Music]
sorry I want this to be as smooth as
possible
[Music]
let's just back out I can I can manage
there was a lot there okay
[Music]
house ruined life ruined I have my gun
let me try out like okay just testing my
buttons before things get crazy Michelle
[Music]
are you doing standing there max why did
I go in the bathroom Oh
[Applause]
oh there's the button there's the button
so rough they shouldn't let me get away
with that that was a sloppy jump but I
got home
F's in the chat please for Max Payne
this is where it all started
do you guys play all three Max Payne
games I did they're good they're great
especially two but oh I can't pick a
favorite you tell me which one you like
the best
although I'm late there you know three
in a while with all the same that was
three years ago
everything ripped apart in the New York
minute the killer junkies had been high
in a previously unknown designer drug
Valkyr V that's what it is the best of
the funeral I told Alex I'd be
transferring to the DEA
it took us three long years to get a
break in the Valkyr case then finally
two months ago a dime dropper tipped us
off the jack Lupino a mob boss in the
Punchinello crime family Thanks perhaps
I would call me a handful traded the
worst mafia family in New York Xbox for
life uh-uh you're on the wrong stream
today friend
I love the Xbox but today we're
celebrating the ps2 it's 20 years old
still hurts
watching that intro huh let's get some
revenge man yep we got a lot of apps in
the chat you guys ever been in New York
very fun still with the black olive with
the Xbox for life I came in from the
cold in the dark outside the city was a
cruel monster
I've been slowly working my way from the
small time to the big fish trying to get
to the source of the drug Alex and bebe
were my only contacts in the DEA the
only ones in this decrepit City who knew
I was down here I hadn't had a
face-to-face with Alex since I've gone
undercover under my coat with the train
doors had already shut behind me and I
was in for the ride
next stop Rosco Street Station and Alex
Philippe prefers macpaint - it's good
one
there's no wrong answer but they're all
so good the station was drenched in
gloom Alex was a ghost nowhere to be
seen
I'd have to look for him every movie or
video game that depicts the New York
subway system there it's always empty
like this and that's the furthest thing
from the truth
remember in the first Ninja Turtles
movie same thing oh my god what happened
here all right getting my buttons oh I
didn't unnecessary jump I just want to
quit my guns I'm scared oh well they
gotta find a food death was in the air
at Rosco Street very I'd have to find
Alex fast
[Applause]
man
how do I open things
now okay hey get all the pain back for a
while
love the narration it's like yeah you
did something right good good
painkillers and bullets baby all right
wasn't Jake's supposed to take care of
you he and Mickey rabbit - yo yo keep
jumping
oh look at that yeah whoo
I kind of got roughed up there how do
you take those painkillers forgot ah
okay switch weapons here I forgot the
controls entirely whoa hang on
oops I first select I didn't mean to I'm
just trying figure out how to take the
painkillers cuz I don't want to go into
that right hey it's me talk with low
health
no I'm using bullet time alright what
everyone's going in I can do it oh they
didn't get them it's such a flex to just
do that bullet time and jump although
I'm not mastering it as smoothly as I
remember what do I gotta do oh well at
least I cleared this room out yo guys Oh
guys hey wait getting around you hear me
wait what
Nocturne says man those sound effects
are ingrained in my memory yeah man
same here it's weird how it's all coming
back not weird just I don't know
nostalgic great I thought you know I
wouldn't remember as much but all the
sound effects the intro all just so
memorable
and this is not a game I went back to
that often you know I played it and I
loved it oh shoot but I didn't go back
and play it as a bunch of other games
[Music]
see you got the shotgun all right it's
only three bullets
here we go gun foo this is the coolest
John wig game it's pretty much the same
thing it's a revenge story for sure
except there's no like underground you
know society there was one for like the
drugs in this game they're a bunch of
drug lords but this is pretty much John
wick before John wick yeah locked
that's bad that's bad
yeah think yeah oh no no purchases today
she should be back oh he shot his own
friend Oh Alexei it ended up in the
middle of a big time crime operation
dual wield for sure I'm still trying to
figure out how to take the painkillers I
thought it was triangle it's circle you
can say goodbye oh me what is this oh I
couldn't save them oh whipped up
there I got I guess I gotta wait til he
makes the O sound and dies I thought I
got him
tonight did the cop live shave me man
what's going on here a massacre these
armed thoughts just appeared from
nowhere we need to get help I can make
the call from the control room one floor
up can you take me there
sure there we go open this up ooh
Desert Eagle mo very good very good
watch out man I need to get this locker
all right let's see if I can escort this
guy huh
all right I think it was shotguns fine
I'll just stick with it we got to go
upstairs locked all right man show me
the way is he still with me
yeah wait I didn't check this door these
guys bring these thugs were hanging out
here man that would never unset feels
pretty cool where's this guy I need to
book one key punch in the password there
you go home free this way all right man
can I creep in the door it's locked
again dude couldn't even punch in the
password before he died dang it let me
in oh well looks like we got to find
another way
all right that did four can I go in the
trash am I supposed hmm where's jump
there you jump is are too strange but it
it works what the heck
hmm just thought I'd try that
everything's blocked I figure out where
to go it's been so long you guys so long
all right the Train didn't work that
door didn't work the tracks aren't
working maybe I already went through
here that's where I found the guy
yeah we're dropping some apps for the
that guy who died that yeah he hit a
police jacket on F's use the keypad what
where I thought I couldn't do it without
his help you know should I shoot the
keypad I think I will that didn't do
jack school it was X look at me oh
goodness
thank you chat
check it out major flex love it all
right well our cop friend could not meet
[Music]
oh shoot another man down
track number two go
now I can take the subway
Bob Jones dodge ya goofed up but wiped
out the whole room still got it
anything in here no it's not that kind
of Locker okay who've we gone yes yes
this wasn't working out the there we go
I want to use these instead there we go
the train lit up like a Christmas tree
power was back on
you guys remember playing this like four
hours
narrating your life afterwards
Ritchie with the conveyance and
[Applause]
there we go
wait a minute that I just won pass an
objective probably
well I can start to clean them let's go
wonderful
[Music]
so much for being subtle yeah you said
it max let me out of here I guess the
only way out is through here what all
right
I've been here what the all right whoa I
know okay moving the train out of the
way so that I can go this way wasn't
blocked off what did that accomplish
yeah this is where it was okay what did
I just do it looks like I busted through
to the other side but the other side
wouldn't let me exit oh well let's
figure it out ah
you guys remember mafia yeah I remember
mafia play Ratchet and Clank I didn't
see it this morning or this afternoon in
the stream room I'm sorry the library
there was a door here I thought I'd look
whatever moving on oh shoot
didn't you
woof ruff schemes George come our gun
food yeah the front door of the train I
got it appreciate it
I need that support from the chat
sometimes I don't know what I'm doing
mafia for sure we should start thinking
about the next game you guys now that I
have a functional ps2 controller Kingdom
Hearts is an option con bros burnout was
a popular choice that you guys were
talking about burnout 3 oh yeah I also
got Simpsons road rage I think I might
play one of those next the rusty door
led to an abandoned part of the station
closed off since the early 40s something
big was going down to Rosco Street maybe
that's why Alex had wanted to meet me
here maybe not hmm one way or the other
I was going to find out let's figure it
out and then maybe check out another
game oh it's so dark I can't see
so this part of the train station hasn't
been open
they saw me gottam I'm getting better I
don't always have to do the gun time
mode but you know I love it so much but
I still like using these better yo-yo
burnout
I don't have the warriors here oh yeah
burnout is fire especially burnout 3 I
love burnout 3 maybe we'll play that
next I couldn't play it earlier because
I had a I was using a different
controller that didn't seem to work but
2 more and Gianluca helped me out
god it's so dark in these caves tunnels
Resident Evil 4 I would but we played
that recent like Lupino now that's
spooky
check the peano yeah spooky but also
it's like the failure town is rising I
wouldn't joke about it if I was new
sorry the controllers are still inverted
burnout okay
burnout seems to be the victor for the
next game I will be playing that next
play around a little little more Max
Payne first because you guys requested
this one to burn out three definitely
guys guys just adjust here what the hell
was that what the hell was that
hey man so whoa Armored Core hmm
good times oh sorry Steve I don't have I
don't have mafia or The Godfather here I
do have Midnight Club though that's
another option what about a Tony Hawk
game that's Tony Hawk for and on were an
option but I didn't bring him today I
love Tony Hawk I kind of first stream I
kind of like I don't consider it as
strongly just because I can mute the
music but God what
getting revenge John wick style as you
guys said at least get to the bank
before switching games okay that was a
polite way to ask what the little smiley
face there Joe Joe appreciate it okay
fellas okay around their way New York's
finest they're gonna be yes I'm at the
vault Disney's extreme skate adventure
Khan Bros I'm not even sure I remember
that tell me more
major flex points great now I'm shooting
up the place and they're gonna blame me
for robbing you I gotta get that whoa
Max Payne damn phone
[Music]
hello Max Payne we come to you now live
from the crime scene aah boys this right
back at you
from the NYPD immediately sure thing Jim
me and the boys have been talking and
everyone's real sorry they'll never do
it again being placed at the scene of a
bank robbery wouldn't have tipped the
odds in my favor grace all right you
guys let's see if we can move on to the
next game I forgot the start button does
that it like keeps rotating around do I
remember Def Jam Vendetta oh yeah I
didn't played that much but a friend of
mine had it mm-hmm
which Tony Hawk was your favorite mine
was American wasteland says DPS mine was
too I love to but I'll be right back I'm
gonna swap out the games we're gonna
play some burnout let's go be right back
actually I can take the mic with me so
you guys still here due to do to do what
you guys think of Max Payne someone said
in the chat that it looks like crap
I think maybe visually it might not have
held up and if I fix the controls I
think that would have been better
ah steve says GTA san andreas hell yeah
probably one of my favorite 6th
generation games it was on the Xbox but
you know I played it on the played on
the PlayStation 2 myself that's also
when I played Resident Evil Code
Veronica which yes definitely I didn't
have the Dreamcast at that point anymore
so I didn't play it there but it got
rereleased I was Code Veronica X on the
PlayStation 2 so Hecky I played that
night club san andreas yeah ah
how good are my driving skills in this
game it doesn't matter cuz we're only
gonna crash cars with to an awesome
soundtrack challenge everything anyone
else think that sounded like
what's-his-name from oh you know hailey
Joe Osmond
it's me sounded like him Resident Evil 4
heck yeah
oh my god
whoo
and then cut it there oh my god this
this game soundtrack also very good
cheyenne says Metal Gear 3 Snake Eater
heck yeah
another oh my god love that game
what new profiles that's right man
let's see I'll just say yeah burnouts
fine with me would you like to save no I
don't have a memory card
yep con bros you remember this intro
autosave will be disabled look I don't
have a choice
no I can't the music world tour let's go
this was the only burnout game I played
there we want to know the quickest route
out of here actually so do i but in the
meantime catch the takedown actions our
burners are just lining up and it's
gonna be sick you're listening to crash
out them alright game alright gang what
parts that hit I don't have any options
top speed they're all about the same I'm
gonna go with this blue black one maybe
turn it down a bit here yeah guys you're
listening to striker on crashes right
just in a few minutes of your time to
cover them no striker know what to do
succeed and burnout you need to be
winning races but you're not gonna win
races unless you take risks all right
maybe a little refresher here won't be
so bad reward that's easy
you earned boost using boost gives your
vehicle a speed no I want to play I want
to play so badly hurry up boost at any
time depressing your buttons here's the
lowdown risks can be taken anywhere in
the burnout world take risks DPS says
I've never played a GTA game with
interest I think driving on the link you
might have said that before or someone
else in the chat and I wasn't confused
cuz like how do you it's hard to avoid
at this point but you know not everyone
has played every game ever it happens
and so it goes on you can even stream
these together to get tore come on and I
know what to do okay pretty much
earning boost is one thing but to win
you need to steal it
yes know what's your competitors by
rubbin slamming slamming
shunt in this was fun this was a great 2
player game yeah trooper troopers well
people have preferences I think he feels
good he's been taking down your
competition come on
how long is one of your rivals and if
you do it you'll grow your boost and
fill it maybe I should have just played
like the single player money you get
taken down your boost bar gets taken
down - ok some thief says I've been
gaming for 30 years that's off - you
frame impact I'm I'm getting there - or
an impact time you can steer your wreck
how cool is that
ok ok Chris is all big flash beckons
very nice but I would love to start
other crashers can't reach that was a
public service announcement brought to
you by crash FM con bro says I missed
split-screen games yeah yeah I do and I
don't like you know especially on the
smaller TVs of yesteryear when
everything was kind of crammed but you
can never replace those memories you
know like Mario Party this game all the
couch co-op games they were good I used
to play Halo that way too
yeah and hey like a mother would suck
Josh up that we are all the air and this
is the latest action from
Silverlake sir let's go recap on the
events so far we've seen takedowns on
all three breaches on the course and
supplying our bees through the edge of
Main Street the lodge is that missed a
lot of the action but after speaking to
one of the burners that's all set to
change want the latest keep it here
Josh fm
[Music]
those is full speed my car is not the
best but you know I didn't have a safe
State Oh got him Tommy
that booth
[Music]
Oh
you know what just to be safe I think
I'm gonna see what I can do about the
audio here there we go we can turn the
DJ off I like that will do I'll turn it
really low ooh you guys in the chatter
saying the DBZ games for sure whoa I got
him Oh
[Music]
oh I'm using the pressure-sensitive
buttons for the ps2 the harder I press
down on the X of fat sorry I went
come on I got to get to the front
out of the way dude
[Music]
whoo 2/3 I gotta use my brakes to turn a
little bit I always I just never
see and look what kind of trouble it
gets me oh my goodness
and I'm out of turbo wait what
[Music]
trading feet
[Music]
Oh jerk
I mean I had to do that right oh that
wasn't me
all right let's go I'm not the eff out
of that guy whoo but I'm still in fourth
place
Oh No very cool sorry guys I need my
full concentration for this talk amongst
yourself okay I'll check in on the tent
just a sec my weight
oh what a pathetic crash like I just
kind of slid to a stop still in 4th guys
I need to get good here
oh what the
get out of here
[Music]
my car cannot go
it's devastating Oh No oh geez
I'm not getting rewards for boost or
anything because I'm just doing bad
the Indians should play that mini mode
where you just crash into cars and see
how much money you can make doing so you
guys remember that that's in this game
there we go there we go
[Music]
there you go got some boost back
I wanted to crash him though it didn't
work
[Music]
he got him you guys believe the
PlayStation 2 is 20 years old shout out
your first game that you remember
playing for the PlayStation 2 not the
best your perks mine came with GTA oh
you know what that's not true
might the one I bought did come with GTA
by sea but I've laid the PlayStation 2
before
know what my first PSC name was
whoa
guys I am losing heart at this I feel
like my car can not go that bad
[Music]
I got to start being a bully here
yeah
damn man it said
look at that I finished
[Music]
Assassin's as a spongebob battle for
bikini bottom
you know that's getting remade right are
like there's a new port on the way
remaster gta3 that was one of my first
ones my cousin had a ps2 before I did
and we played that and I was like oh my
god I think I need one of these
spider-man 1 Metal Gear Solid 2 the chat
is saying Fight Night Round two Kingdom
Hearts the Metal Gear Solid 2 bundle oh
yeah a lot of good answers see all these
games are great no I can't save I have a
minimal gta3 Steve says oh my god amber
Pacific you guys remember this bands
mine was Simpsons hit and run
you know DPS I think you saw it earlier
today because you you've been here for a
while but that that's an option maybe we
can play that next maybe we can play
that last Dave's ex yes wait what the
hell what did I just do
leave backup here
is that the next map that picked the
correct one new here we go let's go all
right after this race I'm gonna play the
mode where you just crash for money
trainer trash that's me
my car is not as underpowered oh yeah
okay
apart from burnout racing you can also
take part in the burnout crash
championship here's everything you need
to know oh I don't want everything - no
- FM confrim says aggressive inline
skating oh my god I saw that in the
library this morning well here's the
ultimate risk and the ultimate reward
[Music]
slam into a true crimes for crime and
true crime streets of LA when it's all
the times we'll figure out how much
damage you've caused time splitters I
don't have it in this pile it's 1 & 2
we're in the library but I don't know
why I thought only I love my parents far
from the truth and we'll let you on to
the next Junction oh and to make things
really interesting Ashley H at my ashley
place some markers for you to hit with
your maxi games you can tag them and
give you dollar increases Need for Speed
Underground - nice guy running his mouth
over here this announcer guy gives us a
chance to talk have either played The
Punisher no I know I didn't know that
was the game till much later I don't
remember but I looked into it and it's
like you can torture people it's kind of
like Manhunters but I never played it
and it kind of came out right after the
movie - Lee's asking can one actually
aggressive inline skate love my look
babe you and I both know that such a
thing exists there are roller skates
without the brakes and they have a
little grind pad in the middle so you
can do cool stuff it's a thing ok not
everyone was a skateboarder let's blade
brought you ever see brink no Ashley has
not alright looks like he is done
chatting let's get into the next race
timesplitters rivals goldeneye for the
best nostalgic co-op shooter for me same
here man
I love me some Goldeneye but I played a
lot of time Twitter's with my cousin all
right here we go
now I'm gonna try alright I think this
is the mode we're talking about we can
just make money to crash
that was terrible
I could have caused so much more Gandy
my goodness is that loud Ashley throwing
up the hang-loose emoji I think if you
press down you see here if I can do it
in Chad think you can do emojis in chat
there we go
man that was so quick there's so much
like number crunching when you're done I
just want to crash some more right now
ah now it's showing the replay I'm gonna
retry that because that was not my best
attempt all right let's go let's cause
some some damage I'm trying to go for
gold a hundred and forty thousand
dollars worth of damage let's go for her
all right got the boost
oh yeah oh yeah look at all look at this
mess
that oh my god I'm causing so much so I
mean that isn't even my fault the albedo
themselves try to get a million Bob
Jones I don't know if I can make that
much well let's see
I only only forty four thousand dollars
of damage Oh fifty going up going up
fine
crash bonus $100,000 worth of damage
silver is not gold I'm gonna try that
one more time
con bro says one of the worst games on
the PSP was 50 cent bulletproof who I'm
replaying that yeah yeah there was even
a sequel like The Sands something like
that hmm
I didn't play that would you like to
save no I don't well made some quick
money maybe we can try that again no
let's try the new map okay crash event
all right you should play Simpsons hit
and run
all right that is on the that's on the
it's in the stack here there's some
there's a little bit of time left let's
see I started this like 215 ish okay
I'll do it right now after this I will
have a little bit of time to play it but
not much but will end their play Red
Dead Revolver
there's no time play college debt man
lives back
where should I crash I just finished I
didn't crash what a joke I'm just too
safe no I didn't get aggressive in mine
it's in the library but I didn't bring
it out today yeah what was that I gotta
redo that I didn't crash into anything I
was I just kind of dodged everything to
see where I could find the biggest crash
zone and it didn't work
I like cheese says rip yeah that was a
terrible run definitely a redo that
look no money was made this should give
me money for being safe no way
this is burnout you know I'll stop there
so I can play a little simpsons hit and
run before we part ways you guys have
been great thank you for being here with
little old me I'm gonna swap out the
game real quick and if you guys like
this idea let me know you know wewe
scream for you so if you like these kind
of this kind of stuff let us know
comments chat whatever cuz I'm having a
ball I could do this all day but time is
escaping me
ah okay
should have brought my water in though
I'm thirsty
check it out for those of you who missed
it we did start off the stream by
playing some Metal Gear Solid 2 although
I was check and recall I was doing
pretty badly I haven't played in a while
I guess
play Need for Speed Underground 2 please
do this more I love retro gameplay yes
love the retro games see I do too
we always try to hit what's new though
you know during the streams but not
everyday there's something you know
there's no there's no game news everyday
or something breaking so oh shoot I skip
the intro damn it was rambling but if
you do like the stuff yeah keep keep
letting me know in the comments because
like in the comments of this video at a
hub because we can do this some other
time you know any excuse to play these
old games today was a very special day
because it was the 20th anniversary of
the PlayStation 2 heck yeah alright
going with Homer woohoo kill zone 1 and
Oh kill zone yeah I didn't bring that
today also but memorable game that
reminds me of like the launch of the ps3
didn't remember when the ps3 launched it
was like a launch title con bro sis
thank you so much for playing my
favorite console ever nice DPS we stream
we change the stream you used to be
11:00 a.m. Pacific Standard Time now it
is 2:00 p.m. Pacific Standard Time we're
going a little over today because I got
the green light from Eric to stream for
like roughly 2 hours because we had a
bunch of games I wanted to play but we
normally stream for about 90 minutes so
much loading we normally stream for
about 90 minutes every weekday so we'll
be back tomorrow you know the scent of
irradiated passengers you say oh my god
a puma tell loyal customer let's go who
is serving me please take me to my cell
oh my god it's right homers car is a
piece of junk anyway and I'm going got
the wrong way
this is so funny all right up who can't
be missing from the kwik-e-mart we gotta
bring him back
oh my goodness
you guys remember this game there was
quite a lot there was always since the
Simpsons have been a thing oh my god I'm
gonna fall since the Simpsons have been
a thing there have always been Simpsons
video games sorry I thought that was a
hole and not a a ramp
I should have ran what I needed to go
did I play this on the Gameboy Advance
no I did not did you let me know Barney
let me know in the chat Barney should be
going to Moe's I don't know where he's
going he's wasted
classic Barney professor Frank let's go
that's something I did always appreciate
back appreciate about most later
Simpsons games they always get the cast
involved there's never anyone else who
like subs in for their voice acting or
anything like that you know never gotta
love it
yeah with some Crazy Taxi the soundtrack
for that would be dope in this pretty
much the same thing it is the same thing
I missed it where are we taking
Professor Frink
to his lab
the controls are pretty smooth despite
how badly I'm pen yeah Azra says this
game was the best gray fox says Metal
Gear Solid 2 was completely underrated
oh yeah not everyone liked riding but I
did I got used to it
and like if you look back on it today
it's still a great game like despite
like the secretive like launch not
secretive lunch but you know how they
did the whole bamboozled thing where you
play as snake first and then the main
game is you play as ride in I don't care
I never really cared I was like oh a new
character but the point that Hideo
Kojima was trying to do or the thing you
was trying to do was make snake seem
cooler
he's already infinitely cool but gunning
alongside of him was there was nothing
quite like hey I get why if people don't
like riding running people over no times
almost up and we're always eight seconds
can't I do it nope nope
I did it yeah now time is up okay that's
fine
spiral says riding was cool - okay guys
I agree that's the point I was trying to
make I like playing his riding he's not
snake but like you know the setup of
Metal Gear 2 was pretty much the same
thing the whole Solid Snake stimulation
really made it feel comfortable like it
was like I was playing part one I love I
love how that was like not crusty sports
like spongebob remember name and address
withheld sweet
[Music]
well thank you very much mister I'm too
good to rag the bus only you succeed and
your exhaust fumes gotta say though the
3d models of the Simpsons characters
will spooky hey mr. plow okay I'm gonna
play as Flanders he's my favorite hide
Leone Moreno is my favorite character in
all of the Simpsons no I can't say are
you sure yeah I can't bro you can try if
you want
wait [ __ ] [ __ ] don't save I'm sure you
don't want to see okay
bamboozled me Flanders blocks alright we
got a few minutes anyway like 15 minutes
less than that about 10 minutes now we
will end the stream with this game
Iroquois Plissken yep yep see you guys
remember of course you do Metal Gear
Solid 2 iconic golden bullet says this
is giving me major nostalgia that's what
it's all about man today we are
celebrating the 20th anniversary of the
PlayStation 2 20 years it launched in
Japan on this day 2000 holy crap we
didn't get to God of War but maybe some
other time maybe when the PlayStation 2
turns 30 so much loading
steal any of my passengers and you'll
pay for it my friend hmm
we turn this up I'm sure we're gonna
have ourselves a busy day see the
cranium friend can you take me to the
kwik-e-mart hold on tight friend I can't
it's a jail that's so cool that he has
the Geo in this game sevens like a t-top
[Music]
than Joey Heatherton don't know who that
is Creston sorry
mrs. Krabappel Oh Neddy I'll take you
the rest of the way take me to see him
or his house
just tell them we're marking tests oh my
god okay by me
I forgot how like I don't know how good
the writing is it's just so enlighted
just feels like a Simpsons episode
that's something mrs. Krabappel would
say it's not yeah but the writing is
very accurate let's go hey we're too
slow and steady wins the race destroy
stuff for a bonus all right
yeah Ned Flanders is horn oh [ __ ] kill
the guy watch out
woo destroy object o4 out of 17 I'm out
I'm not ruining anything here don't
remember that was close
here you go dad that's from Topher muy
bueno me gracias thank you
Oh gotta back up pawns moaning in the
house
hello friend where to Oh take me home
please
okely-dokely do you guys know Hans is in
his 30s
alright it stop telling me to ruin
things so I'm not gonna destroy my neck
that's the horn I can't believe it
whoa this is pretty much like Crazy Taxi
same goals whoa
Bart oh no I saw part G's the time that
tells me to stop destroying things is
when a king
quit doing it here we go here we go
there we go objects not cars okay that
was a problem Bob Jones I see I see
well I brought in Fran the good news
slow and steady wins the race
you guys remember simpsons wrestling on
the playstation one
a lot of people don't land that game I
don't know I have some weird soft cloth
border I think it's funny
see you later commutator hmm and say
that to new record
I don't man Flanders at your service
dude I'm glad whoa
[Music]
Oh yet friend I ran a release
she rag-dolled out of the way oh
goodness no times almost got it turbo
boost gotta get Auto Omar I'm killing
the whole Simpsons family this is
terribly bad up I'm gonna play one more
round of this and call it an upright in
friend more sunny that's okay by me
watch out car oh my goodness
I know why I'm not getting tired of that
horn
[Music]
whoa here we go
[Music]
OOP
[Music]
almost there almost there
[Music]
how many people got a breather economy
painter thanks for the lift Mac oh it's
this apartment hey snake Ned Flanders at
your service
just get me out of here dude hold on
tight friend there you go awesome ride
you rule chief Wiggum we seen you
together out in France you take me home
beep stall my police car slow and steady
wins the race
all right I gotta avoid things for more
four more points whoa
Oh ruin it whatever
[Music]
almost there
[Music]
whoa whoa how many of you in the chat
like your the PlayStation 2 was your
first console let me know it was
definitely not mine I was like 12 when
it came out but uh so many memories with
it still
snake again okay Oh Fran where to
Flanders house please what I've got my
eye on their big screen hold on tight
friend why why did that happen
I'm Flanders look we're gonna take you
to my house I guess I have to
[Music]
it's so weird
[Music]
oh goodness
there we go no score one for old Neddy
next time I'll just steal the car
hello friend where to I need to go to
the kwik-e-mart to get whipped cream
cream okely-dokely do P is 2 and gank
you were my old my og consoles and
golden bullet Sega Genesis says Steam
Sega Genesis was probably mine to that
like simultaneously with the Master
System
here you go friend Nettie I'll take you
the rest of the way
just get me out of here Nomo has lady mo
needs my help so much tell me it
Smithers
that's the kind of attitude we need
though
Flanders thank you well you know what
the guys on that note we will let's see
here I'll go back to this and thank you
all for being here today was so fun
playing all these nostalgic games for
thee now for C now twenty-year-old
PlayStation 2 holy crap
keep leaving the comments what were your
favorite games thank you guys for being
here so much we stream every weekday at
2 p.m. Pacific Standard Time purchase
should be back tomorrow and until then
thank you for joining little old me and
I'll see you next time bye